après deux ans de tractations le cluster
a eu droit à la pose de la première
pierre vendredi 24 février
le cluster des mobilités innovantes qui
sera livrée en 2018 représentera 6 mille
trois cents mètres carrés de surface sur
quatre niveaux 50% de l'espace sera
dédiée à la recherche à la formation
le laboratoire de recherche d'iftar des
pme de la filière des mobilités et vd
comme cohabiteront dans les locaux nous
serons à proximité des pistes ce qui
permettra également de
faire de la simulation d'expérimentation
sur des véhicules
il y aura des ateliers également qui
nous permettront de préparer les objets
et
rassembler les industriels ainsi que les
académiques des chercheurs aujourd'hui
il était prévu pour plus de 200
personnes sur place et qui pourront être
aussi accueillir des
et lentement des start up ou des
chercheurs pour un projet local rang et
le nouveau bâtiment sera construit dans
la zone satory ouest à proximité
d'entreprises technologiques et
industrielles telles que nexter renault
trucks defense ou encore citroën racing
le but faire de ce cluster des mobilités
innovantes
la première vitrine économique de la
région
l'étude de la mobilité décarbonée est
automatique est un sujet mondial ou le
premier qui trouvera les solutions
viendra des marchés mondiaux
le département des yvelines à temps sur
flins menthe renault guyancourt
nous avons poissy avec psa nous avons
vélizy on voit bien que le département
des yvelines est un département avant
tout automobile mais thermique dès 2018
vd comme recevra les voitures touvier de
renault que l'entreprise rendra autonome
le 6 février dernier versailles a été
choisi comme l'une des six villes
d'europe sélectionnés pour tester ces
véhicules qui circulent en auto pilot